Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black panther 2 wakanda forever first look video
we just got a new first look at namor some of
the atlanteans as well as rebel williams iron
heart character and shuri and okoye obviously
the big stuff though is neymar just confirming
some stuff about his character during the movie
the writer of doctor strange 2 was also talking
about his character because he is a member of
marvel's illuminati so i'll explain that too
and there is a big tie to the eternals movie
as well and what's happening in thor love and
thunder which is coming out in a couple days
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're also doing a
ticket giveaway for thor love and thunder all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
post all your name more theories on the video
i'll name a new giveaway winner during this video
too but the first two promos that marvel dropped
are for namor himself who's being played by tenoch
huerta from narcos mexico you may remember him
from something but in these promos he's wearing
different versions of his armor like his normal
armor but then his god enhanced avatar level armor
like black panther wears his black panther suit
even though technically black panther isn't meant
to be the full-on avatar of boss the same way that
khonshu has an avatar in mark spector who becomes
moon knight black panther has a more equitable
relationship with boss like she doesn't manage
him day to day but they just confirmed that namor
is going to have a similar relationship
with one of the gods of the aztec people
also clarifying that a lot of the atlanteans will
either come from ancient aztecs or ancient mayans
but if you look at his version of what you would
call like the black panther style armor like his
armor suit it's inspired by ancient aztec
designs but his headpiece here does feature
a depiction of the aztec god named tapatio he
also has the comic book wings on his ankles too
those give namor the ability to fly through the
air so namor might be flying during this movie
but the concept of the jaguar god comes
right out of real world aztec mythology
he's the god of darkened caves earthquakes
echoes in jaguars obviously god of earthquakes
where does that sound familiar uh reading on
those tremors it was a mild subduction under
the african plate do we have a visual how are we
handling it nat it's an earthquake under the ocean
we handle it by not handling it now everybody's
trying to see how they're connecting all these
dots like maybe that underwater earthquake
had something to do with atlantis neymar and
the jaguar god in the mcu during endgame but if
it wasn't clear atlantis and the atlanteans are
going to descend from a group of aztecs and mayans
maybe that broke off from their culture and just
lived in secret this whole time and it's gonna
be a similar backstory that wakanda had living
in secret with precious resources evolving over
time becoming much more advanced than a lot of
the above land cultures the group of gods that the
atlanteans and the mcu would worship are called
the teteo that's the name of their ruling council
of gods like on moon knight the pantheon that
khonshu comes from has many many different gods
that are part of it like boss for instance the
goddess that black panther in the wakandan people
worship is the sister of khonshu she comes from
that egyptian pantheon but they have their own
ruling council that we saw during the moon knight
series that are called the ennead the aztecs have
their own version of that too the aztecs pantheon
was supposedly formed by a god called quetzalcoatl
much more ancient much more powerful aztec god
big connection to the eternals movie too ajak's
character who salma hayek played was worshipped by
ancient aztecs as quetzalcoatl they believed that
she was their god obviously in the mcu the lore is
a little bit different the backstory they're meant
to be celestial robots basically just pretending
to be gods because of their advanced technology
and their abilities but now they're saying that
quetzalcoatl was an actual mcu god in these
other pantheon of gods including the jaguar god
that namor forms the contract with but here's the
connection to thor love and thunder because the
teteo aztec of gods their pantheon mostly appeared
during the thor comics they also appear during the
thanos infinity gauntlet storyline during the
godhead scene so now it makes sense why marvel
would release thor love and thunder with all these
different gods along with moon knight with this
other god this other pantheon to explain what's
going on with gods in general in the mcu and sort
of set some of these big concepts up before they
use it as a huge twist during black panther 2.
so for instance when the gods are having
their godhead meeting with zeus here with thor
infiltrating in omnipotent city you have hundreds
and hundreds of different pantheons of gods in
attendance here it's meant to be gods from every
different culture like all the most powerful gods
the any it is in the background conscious
pantheon because bost is sitting right here
the aztec pantheon that namor worships and the mcu
gets his powers from is also here in attendance
but it sounds like he'll have a similar
relationship with the atlanteans that boss
had with the ancient black panther characters
so the first black panther was named bashanga
he formed a contract with the goddess bost
who led him to the heart-shaped herb which
gave him all of his abilities and gave him the
power to unite all the different warring tribes
and form the wakandan nation it also gave him
some of his supernatural abilities too that were
passed down like black panther is known as the
king of the dead that's because he can access
the memories of all the previous black panthers
it's kind of like avatar the last airbender with
aang accessing the memories of all the previous
avatars same thing but in the marvel cinematic
universe also the heart-shaped herb is what they
use as a transfer medium to help them access the
different dimension that is the ancestral plane
which we got a big shout out during moon knight
they kind of clarify the afterlife in the mcu just
different dimensions based on your belief system
so for instance when black panthers people die
that worship boss they go to the ancestral plain
different dimension from the duat where the people
who worship the traditional egyptian gods go i'll
explain more about that during black panther ii
because even though bost is a member of conscious
pantheon you think that her worshipers would also
go to that same egyptian afterlife dimension but
remember it's different for every culture so like
you can worship the same god but i think part of
the idea is that she's not a member of the enid so
her belief system is just a little bit different
they kind of clarify that in the comics but it
gets a little more complicated and i don't think
they're going to get into that during the movie
so you don't need to worry about it too much
but presumably when namor's ancestors broke off
from the aztec culture and from the mayan culture
informed atlantis it was a similar situation
with them forming a contract with their gods
helping them survive and form this special
community hidden from the rest of the world
if you look at one of the other promos too you can
see atom he's full atlantean that's why his skin
is blue but he also has a lot of aquatic features
too the reason why namor skin looks like a normal
person's is because one of his parents is
from the land the other is atlantean it's
kind of like an aquaman type backstory where one
parent is normal and the other parent is atlantean
even though technically neymar came first like
they call him the first mutant because he was the
first mutant character whose comic book debuted in
the real world i think what they'll say is they'll
just say that his father came from the ancient
aztecs and his mother came from the atlanteans
but like atom for instance is 100 atlanteans so
that's why he looks like all the other atlanteans
it's the same way in the comics all the atlanteans
in the marvel comics have blue skin like this
looking at his armor it looks like a lot of it was
made from shark bones it's all pretty hardcore but
really cool looking it's kind of the same thing
with the production design during the aquaman
movie too but i think the whole idea in making
him part aztec and kind of leaning on that area
of the world is so that marvel can make this feel
as different from the aquaman movie as possible
but that comparison is gonna be there no matter
what like people are gonna make that connection
no matter what but reportedly the whole reason
why namor hates wakanda hates black panther has
a big beef with him is because of something that
riri williams does while she's a student at mit
and they sort of get caught in the crossfire
like black panther and the wakandans get blamed
for a lot of what happens to atlantis during the
movie but it's a very captain america civil war
type of situation where you have two groups of
characters that are fighting but it's because of
something that a third group does to manipulate
them but in this case i think that it's going
to be some other group there might be some
hidden villain in the movie that's pushing
what's happening with rio williams and there's
just a big accident that happens and they blame
black panther and wakanda for it supposedly
it has something to do with riri williams
creating her new arc reactor technology her new
iron man armor suit that's gonna be like her
mark one type of suit like she'll have
her own version of a cave type scene
they kind of did that in the comics before
she created like the full-on iron heart suit
this is what her arc reactor design is gonna look
like so it's not like she's just gonna take iron
man's old arc reactor and just repurpose it but
it sounds like she's creating some new technology
in there some accident or some other group tries
to manipulate her and what's going on with that
and that leads to the discovery of atlantis
and something really bad happens there like i
said they're meant to have a similar backstory to
wakanda like hidden nation with precious resources
advanced technology that the rest of the world
wants to get their hands on and i think that's
why namor and the atlanteans are so worried but if
they're going to explain what happened to t'challa
black panther during the movie i think it's the
easiest thing to say that namor winds up being
the person to kill him or something that he does
leads to the death of black panther even if he
himself doesn't directly kill him the more recent
comics had tried to portray him like an anti-hero
but during the big secret wars time runs out
lead up like we're happening right now with the
incursions namor was a pretty straight up villain
in fact right before the secret wars event started
before battle world started namor winds up getting
killed by black panther but i don't think that
they're going to do the cabal or anything like
that but they did have a lot of plot with him
in the illuminati in the cabal which obviously is
a big connection to doctor strange too the writer
of doctor strange too said that the reason why
they didn't have namor on their team because that
was a thought initially was just because they
were using the character during black panther
2 and kevin feige wanted him to debut during that
movie not during doctor strange 2 and there were
just so many people from them to pick from in
doctor strange too because they're gonna feature
riri williams first version of an iron heart armor
like her version of a mark one during the movie
we might not see like the full-on iron heart
armor till the iron heart series next year
i don't know if she's going to be involved with
the armor wars iron man series because that's
going to be more of a war machine series maybe
we'll see white vision come back for that too
but because there's so much iron man stuff tied to
the iron heart mythology in armor wars war machine
it sounds like there's going to be a lot of iron
man stuff happening in the next year or two my
full thor love and thunder review video will post
on tuesday after the embargo is up and they let us
all my post credit scene videos my easter eggs
for the entire movie that'll start posting at the
end of next week after it comes out in theaters
congratulations robert martin you're the giveaway
winner for my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for my
new ant-man 3 and new avengers video for all that
footage that just dropped and click here for my
new thor love and thunder trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!